so it's been a lot of time thinking
about why I'm not angel investing as
much lately and I think there's a
conversation that I'd like to make this
video about to start bringing a
conversation to our space about this and
the title this is that you know I can't
code and you can't sell crap and it's
it's an analogy to what I think is going
on right now which is that whether
you're a developer or a designer a CTO
or maybe just an operator as a CEO or a
marketer as a CMO there's a very
distinct personality trait that it needs
to have to be a leader or a CEO or a
co-founder or an executor of a
profitable business it's easy to go out
and come up with a pitch and raise some
money and start a business it's hard to
navigate it through as the world
continues to change and what I'm
realizing and what I like to have people
think about a little bit especially VCS
and angels and more importantly 22 235
year old young women and young men that
are thinking about starting an internet
company or a startup or an app which is
that there's a lot of number twos and
number three's right now
that are trying to run companies I'm not
just the truth there's a lot of players
who would be amazing women right-hand
gals or left-hand guys like just
unbelievable number twos and threes that
are trying to be number ones and we're
gonna see a lot and I mean an obnoxious
amount of companies going out of
business because those those individuals
don't have the stomach to navigate
through the waters and there's this huge
disconnect right now that everybody
thinks they can be an entrepreneur and
the fact that matter is I think in
theory that I can be a great Python
developer but I don't have the matching
talent to pull it off or I can never
really get there I mean I'd love to be
an NBA superstar but no matter how much
flying or effort it's just not gonna get
there and so yeah you could try this
part a couple business and you think the
third time you could pull it off but the
fact that matter is I can't code and you
can't sell crap really sums up how I
feel about the space right now which is
that
there's just a lot of people starting
businesses and they can't win be honest
with yourself look inside yourself
understand that you're that number two
and three that you could be the boost
the turbocharged there's just a lot of
people right now that can make a lot
more money jumping on to an A on number
one instead of trying to start their own
thing big disconnecting the market guys
big disconnect